I just don't get it.
Yesterday, he picked me twice in Duck Duck Goose.
Today, when we were coloring he wouldn't even look at me.
Maggie, you are a beautiful, strong-willed, independent girl...
...and if Johnny doesn't see that, it's his loss.
And he told Dick Rafferty that I have cooties.
Why would he say that I have cooties?
You can't read so much into that Maggie.
Michael said that I had cooties for like all of kindergarten...
...and now we're crazy happy. We're going on three weeks now.
I just want what you guys have. I want a Tommy in my life.
Oh, no you don't.
I mean, sometimes yeah, it's great but with Tommy it's like I give and I give and I give.
And all he does is take.
I think I'm in the friend zone.
What makes you say that?
Well, yesterday at lunch he asked, "Do you wanna be friends?"
Oh yeah! If he asked you if you wanna be friends, you're in the friend zone.
You just gotta be direct.
When Michael started acting all weird, I was like, "Listen, either we're a thing or we're not a thing."
It was the same way with Tommy, he's like, "I'm not ready for a relationship."
And I'm like, "If not now, when?"
We are not getting any younger.
I hear you girl.